when competence when competence
meets business opportunity okay these
two things competence which is the
people and what they can do
okay their specific competence and
the you need the business opportunity
when these two come together
you have this moment of what i call the
spark
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with loamy tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford if you carefully look at
israel's unicorn tech scene
you probably see one thing in common
modi rosen
invested in a lot of them meet modi
managing partner at amity
modi rezan has over 20 years of
experience as a professional venture
investor
he founded magma venture partners in
1999 and led its investment practice
currently he invests out of amity
ventures where he is a managing partner
modi was a seed investor in waze apps
flyer cloud door argus
innovas and many more great israeli
companies mondi rosen
thank you for joining me how are you i'm
great
to see you it's great to see you i can't
believe we're doing this in person this
is
surreal so thank god for the
vaccinations but you know we're in the
beautiful raw shield 20
22 and i'm ethi ventures offices and i'm
so honored to to have this opportunity
to chat with you about your journey
and about the amazing investments you've
made but most importantly about the
humane aspect behind it and who you are
and and why you're doing what you're
doing
and so what i always love to start with
is going all the way back
as far back as you can remember you know
why are you an investor
why join startups as an investor let's
say rather than an
engineer or an entrepreneur or any other
industry in the world
so the reality is that uh
it's it's quite
it happened quite randomly okay so
i can't tell you that it was a
pre-planned journey
okay i i uh conceived the idea of
creating a
venture firm in 1998
uh when venture was really early in
israel okay
it started in israel in 1992. the whole
venture
scene started in 1992. wow there were
actually no
venture firms before that and in 1998 i
came with the idea to create a venture
firm that will
focus on communication just on
communication
communication was very you know before
at those times there was communication
and i t
it was two separate domains and the more
dominant the
the dominant domain was communication
and i had a lot of background in
communications
in actual communication because israel
was very strong at the time in the
companies like eci and ted iran and so
on
and i came with the idea with the noble
idea i can say
of creating a venture firm that will
just do communications
um and i went out to raise the money
with the with a couple of friends
and surprisingly people gave us money
look at that people gave us money and
and we raised our
first fund at the time in 1999 wow
it was a 75 million dollar fund
when the largest fund in israel was uh
just raised and it was 120 million
wow yes that's what it that's that's
what the scene
and we knew a little bit about venture
not a lot
uh but it was a very hot market at the
time the communication market
and people gave us money and had you
told me
that then that the journey would look
the way it looked
i would say no way
the journey was much better than i could
even imagine
so i'm just going to quickly fast
forward here and say that
this journey includes starting multiple
funds raising multiple funds within
those funds investing in some of the
most prominent
companies you mentioned ways earlier as
one of the first investors
from the first time it's what i'm trying
to fathom through
this conversation here is the life of an
investor how you grew as an investor
over these over these decades and so
both on your insights as to the markets
but also your interaction with the
founders
and what you've observed because you've
seen the israeli tech ecosystem
really from the ground all the way to
what it is today right from startup
nation exit nation scale up nation i
mean you're really seeing
everything actively as an active
investor so you're starting out in 1999
in the communication space
do you when you look back now are there
things that you're saying
through the journey that you've
experienced today wow i wish i knew this
back then
well of course of course i mean
one of the things you have to realize
that
uh it's a life is an is a never-ending
journey of learning okay
and as a person you always have to be in
a mode of learning
and development okay that's the most
important thing
that that's that's really what makes the
difference between the best
and those are those are that they're
less
successful okay um
my understanding and i know how my my
capabilities as an investor today
are 20x if not 100x better than when i
started
but in what domain is this indeed you
know i'm saying the market the human
aspect the
the personal calmness what in what
where do you see the big the big jumps
being an investor is a is really
a profession okay it's
people say it's a gut feeling it's you
know it's
luck of course there is a lack aspect in
everything that you do in life there is
a lack aspect
but you being a good investor
is really a profession okay
and it takes you real it takes you a lot
of time to grow
into becoming a good investor
right okay i would say that it probably
takes you five to seven years to become
a good investor okay or
become a reasonable investor and 10 to
15 years to become a really good
investor
that doesn't mean that when you're a
great investor you would not make
mistakes you always make mistakes right
okay but
very rarely when you start as an
investor okay
when someone starts to as an investor
um he's a good investor okay because
there is no
actually there is no school in the world
okay that teaches you how to invest it's
it's surprising there should be
okay and maybe it will develop okay but
um the academia can do much better
actually
in teaching people in a more structured
way
how to invest okay but it doesn't exist
okay
and definitely did not exist 20
something years away
before before when i started there was
no no structure a
place to learn a venture so you learn on
the job
okay but what really the feeling that i
have is that i
really improved tremendously over the
years okay
and because i'm a very analytical person
it beca
it's a very analytical process in my
mind
okay so i i run through a very
analytical process
that some of it has to do with you know
uh
uh of course that there are elements of
uncertainty okay
but you have you you can balance all
those uncertainties into a
right into some some picture of the
opportunity
and i think if you ask me what what
what is really key to anything you do
and it's also investing
um it's the passion that you have
about what to do about what you do okay
passion is really the about what you do
is what makes the difference between
people okay
and it's not it's something that you
cannot fake
okay if you don't have passion about
what you do
you can't really fake it you know it's
it's from your inner
self when you meet
1 000 entrepreneurs that you meet yearly
is this something that you keep in the
back of your mind isn't that important
oh yes it's it's it's super important i
i
um uh there i test for professionalism
okay uh people i like to i
like to see people who are uh you can
see over their career
uh that they're professionals and what
does that mean
professionals does that mean that they
did cool things that they progressed
they were kind of people what does that
mean you know some people
whatever they do whatever they do
they do well okay doesn't matter when
when they cook dinner they cook it well
okay so the extra mile yeah
being being doing well what you do okay
if you if you have
that trait it's super important and when
you look at the
i mean when i'm meeting the i mean they
have a career
behind them right okay it can be you
know
they can be 28 they have 10 years they
can be 38 they have 20 years
when i meet them they they don't start
sunday to be successful most of them
have a track record
and if you will see if you look into it
you will see the
some success success points in the past
right okay and uh and points of
brilliance in
in their past you you can track that uh
and that's the indication of people who
have this
this merit of um professionalism
of passion about what they do uh
of uh of doing things right
you know doing things well and that's
super important
and uh it comes out of uh this this
personality where you always want to
learn
okay you want to understand okay you
want to learn you know do you want to
understand you don't you don't want to
stay on the superficial
right how do you test for that though
you have somebody in front of you
you're meeting hundreds if not thousands
of entrepreneurs on a yearly basis
a lot of the ideas look great a lot of
the entrepreneurs look great because
they're coming in they have three
sessions with you potentially
and anybody can put on a you know a
brave base one of the things that i've
been thinking about is
how do you actually dice you know
differentiate the ones that are
like how do you how do you actually you
know come up with with who they
are from these very short segments
and very short references that's that's
the magic really of being a good
investor right it's being able to
to really understand those people in
front of you beyond the superficial
deck and the zoom meeting that is being
suggested
if you look at the at the
water we're looking what we're looking
for it's if you abstract it
um it's them on the most abstract level
it's when competence when competence
meets business opportunity okay
these two things competence which is the
people and what they can do
okay their specific competence and
the you need the business opportunity
when these two come together
you have this moment of what i call the
spark
you have this you know you can create
something great
okay um
and you you're saying there are so many
ideas there are so many interpreters
that's true
but to find these two things together
where you have a real business
opportunity
and a really competent team that's
actually quite rare
right that's quite rare okay
now actually it's
a little bit more easier to identify a
good team
what's more difficult is to identify
a real business opportunity right
because for that
you really need to understand in markets
you need you really need to understand
the trends in technology
you really and you really have to
understand the specific technology of
what
what they're doing okay all of these
things together
create a business opportunity and that's
really a lot of things to understand
and we as vcs we we have to very fast
learn new new new spaces okay
because we're all all the time you know
we're moving from one thing to another
thing you know
and very fast we have to understand if
there is a
is what i call a good story a good story
is a good business
opportunity okay and that is really
where
where that where the bigger challenge
lies okay
and then on the team side of course you
know what i tell you what gives you
how do you know about the people
obviously the interaction you
you interact with the people you you're
i'm very experienced we are very
experienced
we interact with the people you learn a
lot
from interacting with the people with
the with the entrepreneurs
uh you look at their background what
they did until they meet they met you or
the when they meet you
and from their background you you learn
huge amount of data
okay about who they are okay
um so it's quite fast you you know you
you realize
you know what what what is the person
and what what
what can he do and how good he is and
and so on
and then you analyze the business
opportunity which is actually more
difficult
right it's more difficult so you
deployed hundreds of millions already
in investments walk me through and
return more
welcoming through some of the highlights
so we're not even highlights but you
know memorable
events such as you know being the first
investor in ways you're meeting these
groups
and something triggers something in you
that says i want to be part of this
journey
and lo and behold you know 10 years
later and they
they they help billions of people uh
in in different domains while walking
through some of those highlights
um i can give you
you know i uh the truth is that uh
when i came out from the first meeting
with the three
entrepreneurs of the three founders of
waze
i had a strong feeling that it's a great
opportunity really
after the first meeting yeah and that
was really exceptional because
we're talking 2008
i think it was around march 2008 and the
iphone was start selling
started selling only on june 2007 so the
iphone was
was only nine months on the market i had
a physical gps
in my car i remember that i was holding
to navigate
people didn't know what what's an app
you know how many apps were on the app
stores there
ten thousand ten thousand ten thousand
apps on the app store wow today must be
millions
well it's at least 10 or 20 million
angry so so people didn't know what an
app is
okay um
but i can tell you that when i came out
of the first meeting i had a
strong hunch that this is a great
product okay then of course we did due
diligence and all of that
i'll give you another another example
you know i i was the
uh the first investor in a company
called innovis
okay which is the lighter for autonomous
vehicles small small
company yeah it's it's a great company
and i i was you know i really i was
literally the first person who told the
entrepreneur we
we were going to give them a money then
other
other also came in in the in the in the
first round
but i was the first one and what really
drove that decision
is a couple of things it's uh first of
all the
the understanding or the belief that
autonomous vehicles is something that is
going to happen
okay so i i looked at the technology i
looked at
ai i understood danny and we're talking
early 2016. it was early days of ai
okay yeah hey i started or really in
2015 to become a viable technology
but in 2016 i believed ai is going to
uh i mean neural networks are going to
change computer vision
i really understood that so that's about
the technology trends
but the other thing is that the
interpreter
really developed similar technology for
other applications
so he was really migrating a technology
that he was repurposing the technology
from other
domains to and that is a
that is something that i really liked
okay that i knew that he has a lot of
experience
in in doing this technology for other
with
for other applications that i didn't
believe in okay he was not successful in
his previous uh
any in the previous applications but for
autonomous vehicles
this this technology was great right
um so you know so i it was a great team
it was obviously a great team in innovas
i mean very strong guys for instance
the repurposing of the technology plus
the belief that dr nomio's driving
is going to be a big thing is really
what drove the decision to make this
uh this investment okay so if you if you
analyze it it's
uh on one hand you you have to
understand mega technology trends
you have to understand that you know ai
is is actually
and it's not easy because you you know
why it's not easy
because there are always mega
technologies trends that are
that that appears that appear to be
happening but they are what i call false
alarms
right they actually don't don't happen
right
okay like if you think uh there was a
lot of hype around virtual reality
i remember not not a few years ago now
it may happen
10 or 20 years from now but for now
right
so you have to understand those mega
trends and what is really happening
which trend is going to actually
materialize
that's part of your of your bet you have
to understand those technology and you
have to
to to understand how it will develop big
markets
right how it will how big markets you
know autonomous
driving is going to be a huge huge
market will take another
it's it's just starting now but in the
next decade it's going to be a huge
phenomena for us
right i mean i think that part of it is
also understanding the butterfly effect
and where's the ripple going to reach
and how is this going to impact the rest
of your trajectory because even if
you're not investing directly in
autonomous vehicles
if you're investing in another sector
every sector is going to be impacted
by the autonomous driving revolution
absolutely going you know every sector
in 2008
was going to be impacted by the fact
that now you have the democratization
of mobile applications yeah and no
matter if you're investing in fintech
and insurance and in consumer whatever
it is
you know these understanding these mega
trends it sounds like it's relevant
regardless of regardless of where you're
investing absolutely
what i always say is that you have to
understand what i call tectonics
changes yes there are tectonic changes
in the industry
and you have to identify them they
create a lot of opportunities right and
if you look at the history of the
technology a lot of the opportunities
were driven always by tectonic changes
um let me mention some you know social
network
social networking for instance started
around the
early 2000s facebook twitter okay there
was no social web
okay that was a tectonic move tectonic
change then in 2007
started the smartphone again a tectonic
move okay
around that time started the started the
started um the cloud the public cloud
phenomena started you know i mean amazon
web services started really in 2006
okay very early days i mean it's still
it's still early days for uh
for uh for public cloud okay but that's
a huge tectonic shift
that's a huge tectonic shift who who
created a lot of value
migration across the industry okay and
in 2015 ai started neural networks
really started to become
an applicable relevant technology in
and we have invested you know in 2015
and 16 in
ai in fabulous companies like uh
site to mention one in the area of
e-commerce
uh like aa doc in in the area of uh
of uh of medicine of a
of digital red radiology yeah
and so on so so these are the it's and
it's always many times it's driven by
tectonic changes
i love it modi thank you so much for
spending this time with me
and i look forward to seeing everything
that immediately does and
your journey is just it's it's inspiring
i think in in
the the most basic sense of just this
idea of continuing to improve and
improving this one percent every day and
continuing to be curious
and the three words is the passion
passion about what you do
that's the truth you just saved me that
whole question
passionate about what you do i love it
thank you very very much
thank you micah great great talking to
you and i look forward to sitting here
next time with it with the pitch deck
one day
you're welcome